how did Putin get to the top financially
well like all billionaires his primary
source of wealth is acid starting with
stakes and companies Putin is speculated
to have massive sticks and a handful of
oil Giants this includes a 37 stake in
Circ enough to guess a 4.5 stake in Goss
prom and at least a 75 stake in gunver
all these companies are extremely
private and some of them have even
rejected the notion that Putin is a
shareholder similarly Putin also has a
vast portfolio of real estate holdings
including 20 different palaces and
davilas and we're not talking about real
estate worth of tens of millions or even
hundreds of millions some of these
Holdings individually clock in at over 1
billion dollars Putin of course denies
owning these Estates and it may be true
that he doesn't directly own these
properties but it's speculated that
Putin owns all these stakes and
properties through various proxies one
of Putin's political colleagues
stanislav balkovski suggests that Putin
is worth at least 40 billion dollars and
in terms of an upper bound he has no
clue